- I'm lucky.
I don't know if y'all feel like
you have these kind of girlfriends.
I have very, I don't know
if I have these girlfriends,
or I force them to be this sort of thing,
but I'm very open about everything.
- That's great.
- Like I'm like,
everything is on the table.
'Cause I feel like I'm a human.
You're a human.
We go through the same things, right.
And if we're not,
then maybe something's wrong with me,
so let's figure that out.
So, do you have those girlfriends
that you feel like you can
kind of talk about anything?
- Oh yes.
- Yeah.
- I talk about diarrhea all
the time with my best friend.
- [Kelly] There you go.
There you go.
- All the time.
- [Kelly] Sometimes it happens.
- Sometimes you want
it, sometimes you don't.
- Sometimes you want it.
- Well see, that's funny
because I used to hate scatological humor
and now as a kid they think it's the most,
the toddlers think that
that is the only funny thing
in the world.
- My six year old, not a toddler,
literally ran around going "Oh my God,
you're so funny my pants came off!"
And he just like would pull his pants down
and show me his butt.
And they think it's hysterical.
He thinks it's hysterical.
My daughter, who's
eight, thinks it's funny.
There's so much poop talk in my house.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- You just have to be okay with it.
This is, she's--
- Am I your child?
- She's building an
invisible chastity belt.
She's just like, she's like,
like it will not happen.
- Lock it up.
- It is fun.
It's a blessing.
- Yeah, try cleaning
diapers with these talons.
- Yeah.
- Note to self.
You aren't cool.
Cool girl and mom.